finalement en l'état actuel des
capacités minières connu la part
chinoise et réserve mondiale est de
l'ordre de 37 % dans la cadre de la
guerre commerciale avec les états unis
la chine utilise sa position comme
levier de négociations mais il est clair
qu'avec les pénuries et les tensions que
nous allons connaître sur certaines
terreur il faut envisager d'autres
solutions
[Musique]
excellent 14 juillet à toutes et à tous
et bienvenue sur arte france pour deux
heures d'émission comme chaque soir du
lundi au jeudi
analyser à débat décryptage l'essentiel
de l'information avec nos invités et nos
reporters sur le terrain tout de suite
place au titre hommage aux victimes de
l'attentât de nice qui a fait 86 morts
le 14 juillet 2016 présents dans la cité
azuréenne tout à l'heure pour une
journée de commémoration cinq ans après
le premier ministre jean castex et le
garde des sceaux eric dupond moretti en
toile de fond la lutte contre le
terrorisme
[Musique]
après une année sans coville 19 oblige
la france à renouer avec son
traditionnel défilé militaire le dernier
du mandat d' emmanuel macron parmi les
participants des soldats de la task
force takouba qui réunit à huit nations
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme au
sahel
et ce alors que le chef de l'état a
annoncé la fin de l'opération barkan
dans la région pour début 2009 une
tribune signée vladimir poutine le chef
du kremlin a rédigé un texte sur
l'ukraine pour mettre en exergue l unité
historique entre les peuples russe et
ukrainien une analyse des relations
entre moscou et kiev pour montrer je
cite la russie que la russie cherche des
compromis et des solutions acceptables
qui convienne à tous
[Musique]
journée d'hommage à nice 5 ans après
l'attentât du 14 juillet 2016 qui a fait
86 morts et plus de 400 blessés en
pleine célébration de la fête nationale
sur la promenade des anglais présents
cet après midi le chef du gouvernement
jean castex le garde des sceaux eric
dupond moretti et la ministre déléguée à
la citoyenneté marlène schiappa objectif
rendre hommage aux victimes à la nation
tout entière a souffert avec elle et n'a
rien oublié de leur drame et à toutes
celles et ceux qui ont perdu un être
cher
je veux le redire ici avec mes mots et
avec mon coeur ne n'oublieront jamais
leur nom leur visage leur parcours
pas plus que nous n'oublierons nanites
devillers simone barrette aussi tu vas
et vincent lokace lâchement assassinés
eux aussi par un autre terroriste
le 29 octobre 2020 à l'intérieur de
notre dame de l'assomption
la journée du 14 juillet 2016
reste un traumatisme pour les familles
des victimes valentin carpentier bruno
raffi trimaud et père de deux enfants le
14 juillet 2016 alors qu'il est en
déplacement professionnel
sa femme se rend sur la promenade des
anglais pour assister au feu d'artifice
avec leur fils aîné
ce soir là elle perd la vie lorsqu'un
homme fond sur la foule avec un camion
cinq ans plus tard
ce père de famille se souvient je les ai
récupérées le lendemain dans l'après
midi
et quand on s'est vus j'ai presque je
les ai pas vus parce que pas les aveux
je n'ai pas reconnu quelques parents en
fractions de secondes comme ça parce
qu'il avait vraiment le visage ça se
voit qu'ils ont vécu quelque chose comme
bruno et ses enfants des dizaines de
familles touchées par cet attentat qui a
fait 86 morts tente de se reconstruire
pour les aider de nombreux
établissements les suivent
c'est le cas de l'hôpital lenval qui se
chargent de la psychiatrie de l'enfant
dans les semaines et les mois qui ont
suivi l'attentât
l'établissement a accueilli de nombreux
jeunes traumatisés il est très important
de d'organiser une bonne prévention pour
les enfants dans les écoles
c'est tous les partenaires de la
pédiatrie et de l'enfant lorsqu'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est les plus fragiles ceux
qui ont déjà terrain de vulnérabilité
seront les plus impactés suite à cette
tragédie
nice a accentué sa sécurité par le biais
de son maire christian estrosi
la ville a installé des centaines de
caméras de vidéosurveillance
et considérablement diminué depuis 2015
ça semble un petit peu paradoxal par
rapport au fait que la menace terroriste
soit toujours présente ça veut dire quoi
exactement est ce qu'un paradoxe non il
ya un paradoxe c'est une évolution à des
de la lutte contre ces groupes
constitués en fait il ya eu plusieurs
plusieurs périodes on va dire dans les
attaques islamistes
il y à une période où j'étais à la
déviation à l'époque ont traité et on
surveillait les filières liées à al
qaïda à l'époque avec avec surtout en
europe avec la en suède en à londres un
bien connu c'était le long de l'histoire
à cette période il y a eu après le 11
septembre
enfin le 11 septembre a déclenché enfin
à prouver que des groupes de terroristes
islamistes comme al qaïda était capable
de de préparer et de commettre des
attentats de grande envergure dans un
état occidental et ensuite on a eu
plusieurs attentats je pense à l'espagne
l'année suivante je pense évidemment en
france où il faut avoir des moyens
financiers des moyens humains et
logistiques considérables pouvoir
préparer se déplacer et commettre les
attentats et la chose assez simple chez
eux c'est que ils n'ont pas besoin de
repartir
donc c'est déjà une grande partie du
travail qui est accompli c'est à dire
s'infiltrer commettre l'attentât se s et
ceux et combattre contrôler les forces
d'intervention
aujourd'hui la menace a changé la menace
est présente au quotidien
déjà il faut pas parler de terrorisme
sans parler de l'idéologie qui est
présente en europe de plus en plus
présente en europe depuis 2001 qui a
démarré selon moi depuis 1928 avec la
création des frères musulmans est là et
leur doctrine qui s'est répandue et qui
a été utilisé par de nombreux groupes
islamistes
aujourd'hui monter un attentat de grande
envergure type 11 septembre ou type 13
13 novembre en france est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que tous les services de
renseignement occidentaux européens et
français
les français se sont adaptés ont déployé
de nombreux moyens de surveillance des
infiltrations d comment dirais-je des
des sources aussi de façon à anticiper
ces gros attentats en revanche les
attentats qui peuvent être commis par
des personnes qui se sont qui adhèrent
au projet islamiste qui décident de
passer à l'action à leur propre
initiative avec un camion c'est vous
avez dans votre d'abord à votre sujet
vous avez fait référence à la au triste
anniversaire de l'attentât islamiste à
nice donc aujourd'hui n'importe qui qui
la dérange islamistes mais forcément le
biais d'un groupuscule et des
organisations organisés sont plus des
personnes individuelles qui agissent
maintenant doudou la difficulté la
complexité évidemment on a bien compris
pierre martinet mais messieurs
j'aimerais revenir sur la ministre des
armées florence parle et qui s'est
exprimé tout à l'heure je cite il y aura
une place majeure de takouba dans les
prochains mois et prochaines années dans
le cadre de la transformation de
l'opération barkan takouba n'a pas
vocation à se battre à la place des
maliens si le contingent est moindre au
sel
n'y at-il pas un risque qu'elle est
terroriste viennent plus facilement en
europe
cette question elle est pour vous
monsieur cissé mais juste avoir gardé
quand même cette infographie 2
de florence parler nous ne quittons pas
le sahel nour et adaptons notre
dispositif nous le transformons de façon
profonde
nous avons rencontré des succès dans le
combat que nous menons contre les
groupes terroristes
ben ça bouillait si c'est le fait que le
contingent soit donc moindre au mali et
plus généralement au sahel est ce que ça
ne peut pas créer bien des brèches pour
l'europe ensuite est que des attentats
soient commis sur le vieux continent
alors ce que je voudrais dire par là il
y tant que les africains aussi assument
leur propre circuit ne pas se traiter sa
défense et sa sécurité
bien entendu il ya natra dépendance et
tous les pays
thor s'unir contre le terrorisme les
huit ans que les états du sahel s'assume
en tant que parlementaire si un petit
peu vous en ont les moyens de leurs
établissements
oui vous savez souvent pas que dans
l'ensemble ça fait huit ans de présence
de forces étrangères sur le sol malien
il est en amont a donné que les
arguments tant puissance pour l'instant
nous avons quelques insuffisances ça il
faut le reconnaître
et si taguba si la mission pack 1
prenait fin en décembre 2022
enfin 21 22
j'espère que cela nous laisse du temps
aux armées du sahel de montée en
puissance du sua heureux de partager ce
plateau avec monsieur martinez qui est
un spécialiste de la question et
quelques voix près d'accord avec ce que
vous venez de dire en tous les cas il ya
eu des polémiques la tête de pierre
martinez en tant que professionnel en
partie d'accord
france 2 et de la sécurité je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec les qu il ya une
insuffisance me mois nous rapportant que
malien il est temps qu'on sort 2e de
cette histoire de tri jean demandé à la
cour internationale d'être à nous tuer
parce que temps pour ça je le dis
clairement je suis d'accord avec
monsieur martin r mais ça fait huit ans
de présence de forces étrangères sur le
lien pour quel résultat pour quel
résultat c'est la question que doris
pausini donc un moment donné est ce que
la formation qui est qui est dispensée
par le heat et d'autres contingents il
est temps de l'évaluer et c'est là c'est
à partir de là nous allons comprendre
enfin où est ce que nous en sommes nous
aussi
moi je pense qu'il faille un moment
donné se mettent autour de la table et
discuter même avec les plus grands avec
et les ehpad artistes parce que au mali
ce n'est pas du terrorisme en réalité
c'est plutôt il ya beaucoup de
narcotrafiquants il ya beaucoup de
grands banquiers savaient donc l'outil à
10 ans en parlant de dia qui elle
voulait pourtant al qaïda au maghreb
islamique et d'autres groupuscules comme
cela pierre marché pour saisir aux
propos de bénéfices et non vous avez les
non et non al-qaïda et aux autres quand
on en rajoute du slam d'arrière voilà ce
sont des propos droite le galvauder une
longue balle au centre et au nord on
note essentiellement des
narcotrafiquants et on voit ce qui était
d'abord de la rébellion pour
l'indépendance de l'azawad aujourd'hui
sont avec moi au parlement de la
transition pour coup sans nommer les
ministres dont ils reconnaissent leur
moyenne t aujourd'hui les maliens sont
en passe de se réunir doussain six mois
sur le dialogue même avec les
irrédentistes pierre martinet alors je
suis en partie d'accord est ce que parce
que monsieur vient me dire c'est je suis
absolument d'accord avec lui quand il
dit qu'il faut absolument
pardonnez moi l'expression mais je vais
l'image et ils soient absolument relever
la béquille de l'europe et de l'occident
de la france je suis absolument d'accord
avec vous permets moi dans mes
compositions dans les propositions que
je fais dans les différents états
africains parce que je travaille
essentiellement avec l'afrique c'est il
ya un ministre africain qui m'a dit
merci parce que vous allez nous aider à
ne plus être aidées il
il est impératif de faire de la
formation par des sociétés autres que
des états je fais pas de la publicité je
ne fais pas la publicité mais de façon à
former les formateurs et en dix ans
maintenant colonel
françois qui a commandé la taskforce
takouba au mali et de janvier à avril 1
il a dit il faut se concentrer sur la
construction de l'ami plutôt que la
destruction de l'ennemi
c'est peut-être ça ce que vous voulez
dire mais est-ce que c'est suffisant 50
50 ans et 50% devraient les 50% il faut
il faut faire les deux mais moi je suis
je suis convaincu que la que les armées
africaines que ce soit au mali ou
ailleurs parce que j'ai été dans
d'autres pays ont les moyens en les
capacités à se débrouiller seul il y
aura un temps d'adaptation mais moi je
pense qu'il faut changer le
considérablement dès maintenant ce
logiciel là c'est à dire ne pas attendre
de la coopération mais d'avoir une
collaboration et avoir de la formation
formation de formation de formateurs et
ensuite être autonome
le but le but de takouba notamment je me
permets de vous couper parce qu'on a un
sujet à passer et vous allez parler
après pierre martinet plus que monsieur
on sait que la lutte contre le
terrorisme
elle passe par le combat sur le terrain
contre les groupes djihadistes au sahel
il ya d'ailleurs eu en ladhuie tout à
l'heure lors du défilé militaire sur les
champs-elysées un contingent de 73
membres de la task force de coups bas
qui opère donc au sel et qui regroupe
une nation pourtant emmanuel macron a
annoncé la fin de l'opération barque à
naucelle pour le début de l'année
prochaine
on en a parlé il ya quelques instants
alors comment lutter contre le
terrorisme sur le terrain à la source
avec l armée éléments de réponse avec
clément delcourt élèves masculins
guillemard aussi
[Musique]
gagner l'avenir c'était le thème de
cette édition 2021 de la parade
militaire du 14 juillet un avenir qui
s'annonce plus sombre et qui devrait
renouer avec les conflits de haute
intensité
c'est en tout cas l'hypothèse
privilégiée en haut lieu
nous sommes confrontés à une situation
où la pluralité des conflits possibles
est extrême mais surtout leur degré
d'intensité
c'est à juste titre nos armées se
prépare à des scénarios de combat de
très haute intensité durable 27
septembre 2020 la guerre éclate entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan dans le
haut-karabagh une guerre éclair et
meurtrière plus de 5000 morts en 44
jours mais surtout un conflit
conventionnel qui voit s'affronter deux
armées employant tout l'attirail
militaire avions de combat artillerie
système de défense anti-aérien
brouillage électronique drones forces
spéciales ou propagande sur les réseaux
sociaux
un avertissement pour certains
observateurs qui voient un retour aux
guerres de grande ampleur pour bientôt
au moment où arménien et azéri en
décousaient un haut gradé militaire
français thierry burkhard chef d'état
major de l'armée de terre tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé
demain les affrontements sont encore
plus dur et il ya une autre échelle avec
une autre intensité on a changé
en fait le monde a changé et la
confidentialité est en train de changer
la guerre la france y est habituée elle
qui déploie ses soldats sur de nombreux
terrains d'opérations extérieures les
fameuses opex depuis des décennies
afghanistan syrie libye sahel mais ces
derniers conflits sont dits asymétrique
et ne sont pas comparables aux guerres
annoncée pour demain
cela fait plus de dix ans que l'armée
s'est concentrée sur la menace du moment
qui était le terrorisme militarisé en
prévision de ces nouveaux conflits
la france ça remet de nouveau son budget
augmente de 1,7 milliard d'euros chaque
année depuis 2018 et devrait atteindre
44 milliards en 2023 soit plus de 25 %
de hausse en cinq ans pour autant cela
ne suffit pas du moins si l'on en croit
celui qui est encore chef d'état-major
des armées jusqu au 21 juillet la loi de
programmation militaire actuelle
aujourd'hui ne vise pas une montée en
puissance ou l'acquisition d'une masse
qui permettrait à l'armée de s'engager
dans un conflit étatique majeur deux
généraux mais un même constat
et ce n'est pas un hasard si le général
thierry burkhard un homme de terrain qui
a servi en irak et dans l'ex yougoslavie
a été récemment désigné pour remplacer
d'ici à une semaine
le général françois lecointre avec pour
objectif la préparation de la défense
française à des conflits d'ampleur et de
nature différente et la fin de
l'opération barkan au sahel qui
permettra le rapatriement de 3000
soldats français s'inscrit clairement
dans cet objectif
pierre martinet d'un côté on augmente le
budget dans notre côté on l'a dit on se
désengage du sahel difficile de
comprendre là la stratégie la ligne
directrice tout ça pour le rappel lutter
contre contre le terrorisme c'est le
postulat de départ de ce décryptage
alors c'est compliqué de lui moi
j'écoute je vais vous résumer la
situation
un proverbe qui paraît-il et viennent
des talibans
l'occident à la montre et nous avons le
temps donc effectivement on s'engage sur
des opérations pour stopper un califat
on va dire qu'on s'est engagé au mali
pour stopper en italie faire puisqu'une
parlant du mali je suis avec mon ami
malien et on s'engage pour le stopper
militairement le stop parce que
l'occident ait les moyens matériels
humains militaire de stopper un califat
comment dirais-je qui n'est pas une
armée conventionnelle qui est plutôt des
groupes de guérilla on va dire mer comme
on fait quoi on y reste dix ans quinze
ans c'est impossible en fait comment le
comment voulez vous que la population
présente puisse accepter une armée
étrangère même si au départ elle est
venue pour aider puisse accepter une
armée étrangère 10 15 ans 20 ans plus
tard sur le territoire il ya un an donc
maintenant comme vous dites c'est
enlever la béquille pour pouvoir aider
l'armée malienne ban se mouiller si
c'est maintenant que
barkan s'en va takouba est là qu est ce
qui va se passer concrètement concret
excusera concrètement ce qui doit se
passer c'est que effectivement il va y
avoir des forces spéciales qui vont
ponctuellement et éliminer des poches de
terroristes islamistes
mais il est il est plus urgent que nos
amis africains que nos frères africains
prennent leur destin en main et ils ont
la capacité humaine technique
psychologique ils ont toutes les
capacités jeu pour avoir formé des
armées africaines je sais qu'ils sont
plus autant capable connu que de faire
de le faire il n'y a pas de problème
martinez je laisse à bam se mouiller si
c'est parler puisqu'il a un peu moins
par les besoins et ouais alors
effectivement ce que dit pierre martinet
et utah sucre un moment donné il faut
qu'on prend on nous met la béquille il
faut l'enlever faut l'enlever du dj à
dose homéopathique et ne vont pas mettre
mieux pratiquer le fait de se retirer
complètement début début 2022 ou j'en ai
eu des alertes je pense quand même on
les dit salaire qui est au mois de juin
une décision du président mc ren qui
avait décidé d'arrêter les opérations
conjointes
donc l'armée malienne donc mais il est
témoin de vous couper est-ce que c'est
pas entre guillemets une sanction par
rapport à tout ce qui s'est passé au
mali récemment entre le coup d'état
dernier on a parlé d'un deuxième coup
d'état ensuite avec si meego italie a eu
la cedeao il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont passés au mali c'est difficile à
comprendre
l'escapade derrière la france qui a dit
bon on se retire parce que là ça devient
trop compliqué alors moi ce que je suis
pas être trop alarmiste ou alarmant mais
il nous explique le sahel et jean
indique pierre martinet peut le
confirmer si le ciel tombe à cause du
terrorisme parce qu'il ya quand même été
du terrorisme malgré tout pas forcément
qu'au mali et le niger donc si le seuil
de ton c'est aussi le domaine s'il
réussira encore plus proche des
portelois lopez extérieur s'il n'est pas
anodin il
la france n'est pas là que pour y
demeurer c'est aussi pour se préserver
éviter justement que ce terrorisme
militarisé prépa l'envergure sur son sol
et le temps réel sur l'ensemble de
l'europe dont va être sur 5 jeudi qu il
faut faire attention de vouloir se
retirer à tout prix ou de mettre la
pression parce que guerrier de coup
d'état ou de coup de force des
militaires
vous savez souvent les pays comme la
france je suis d'accord c'est s'endetter
démocratie il faut qu'ils comprennent
que nous avons 60 ans d'indépendance
nous avons pas descendre que deux
seraient 200 ans du république et moins
souvent je le dis je ne suis pas à la
date des coups d'état mais perd martinez
est un témoin privilégié pour dire que
la gabégie mois de pourparlers destinés
à autre chose son la pose de ses coudes
et dan dah tant qu'il ya une nouvelle
gouvernance
on aura des coups d'état donc où les
deux condamnés ou de mettre la pression
pour les coups d'état on devrait d'abord
condamné ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont
censés être représentatifs de la
population
il tient en main les destinées du pays
et qu'il faut du grand n'importe quoi à
terme de gestion financière en termes de
gabegie et de vol d'escroquerie toujours
si l'élite des anciens du village sur
les propos s'il vous plaît si vous
permettez classement des canadiens et
prétend voilà le propos de monsieur
bazin devant le juge jean emmanuel
macron moi je rechute et qui lui
tiennent sur le sol africain
parce que moi je les interprète tu
l'analyse comme s'il était parti
chercher un petit peu la protection de
mâcon macro ne le protégera pas c'est à
lui de travailler dans son pays
sinon on peut aussi ne sera pas à l'abri
d'un coup d'état ça c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui vous avez une coalition qui
est là vous avez dit militaire monsieur
marty
le type qui s'assume et des militaires
maliens nigériens tchadiens qui s'assume
et qui alimente ogier merci merci c'est
la fin de ce décryptage merci ben oui et
si c'est d'avoir répondu à une question
vous êtes parlementaires maliens un
membre du conseil de la transition à
bamako merci également à vous car
martinez ex agent de la dgse et
fondateur de wind corp security à
défense restait sur rt france dans
quelques instants
focus sur la grande avancée diplomatique
en israël avec l'inauguration de
l'ambassade des émirats arabes unis à
tel aviv
c'est le troisième pays arabe après
l'egypte et la jordanie à s'installer
dans l'état hébreu
et puis zoom sur la tribune de vladimir
poutine le président russe qui a publié
un texte dans lequel il analyse
l'histoire et les relations actuelles de
l'ukraine et de la russie
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse d'industrie
elle est extrêmement contre les
coupables puisque on reverse 50 5 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires à l'état et à
la commune ils sont donc très intéressé
au fait que le fonctionnement soit clean
on fait exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurances est ce qu il ya
de l'argent suspect nous sommes dans
l'obligation de le déclarer comment se
répartit 100 euros de mise globalement
aux machines à sou par exemple moi j'ai
dans l'obligation de vendre en moyenne
85% que nous on n'a absolument aucun
intérêt à ce que quelqu'un aille
raconter qu'il cheruiyot casino pas
certains pouvaient dépenser des sommes
extrêmement importantes allant jusqu'au
million d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe
mais on est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nombre
[Musique]
il
il est 20h30 heure de près de paris très
heureux de vous revoir sur rt france
inauguration tout à l'heure de
l'ambassade des émirats arabes unis en
israël
après l'egypte après la jordanie il
s'agit du troisième pays arabe à
disposer d'une représentation
diplomatique à tel aviv syriana vitesse
mulhousien drapeau hissé devant la
bourse de tel-aviv
l'ambassade est prête à recevoir ces
diplomates émirati cette nouvelle
mission diplomatiques entre les deux
états apportent un message clair
travailler ensemble dans un climat de
paix je suis si heureux d'avoir
l'occasion au début de mon mandat de
président de l'état d'israël de
participer à cette ouverture historique
de l'ambassade des émirats arabes unis
en israël l'ouverture de cette ambassade
est une étape importante dans notre
cheminement commun vers un avenir de
paix de prospérité et de sécurité au
moyen-orient
cette ambassade ne servira pas seulement
de maisons pour les diplomates mais de
base pour notre tâche qui consiste à
continuer de construire ce nouveau
partenariat de chercher le dialogue et
non la dispute de construire un nouveau
paradigme de paix et de fournir un
modèle pour une nouvelle approche
collaborative de la résolution des
conflits au moyen-orient
les émirats israël avait annoncé la
normalisation de leurs relations à l'été
2020 lors de la signature des accords
d'abraham contenu sous l'impulsion de
l'ancienne administration américaine de
donald trump des accords qui permettent
une coopération dans un large éventail
de domaines notamment le tourisme
l'éducation la santé le commerce et la
sécurité
le 29 juin dernier la concrétisation se
poursuit et le ministre des affaires
étrangères israélien yaïr lapid se rend
à abou dhabi pour y ouvrir une ambassade
de l'état hébreu une visite
kr est intervenu lors de la montée des
tensions entre le hamas et israël qui
avait agacé le mouvement islamiste
palestinien au pouvoir à gaza
en ouvrant une ambassade dans un état
d'occupation les émirats poursuivre le
péché nationale qui l'ont commis en
signant l'accord de normalisation ça à
l'heure de la cause palestinienne et
sert le récit de l'occupation c'est un
coup de poignard dans le dos des
palestiniens qui ont mené la bataille de
l'épée de jérusalem demandant le retrait
immédiat de ce péché de la normalisation
avec l'occupation des émirats devrait
annuler cet accord l'année dernière
bahreïn autres monarchies du golfe ainsi
que le maroc et le soudan avait
également rejoint les accords d'abraham
pour pacifier un peu plus leurs
relations avec israël et pour évoquer
les normalisation des relations entre
israël et les pays arabes le
géopolitologue gérard vespière fondateur
du site le monde décrypté et chercheur
associé à la fée mot la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient
bonsoir géré avec pierre merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation egypte jordanie
et donc émirats arabes unis depuis
aujourd'hui une ambassade en israël
concrètement ça change quoi au soir
avoue bien écoutez c'est un
développement qui va dans le sens de
l'apaisement et dans le sens du
rationnel au détriment de l'émotion a je
crois qu'il y à un commentaire
intéressant celui du ministre des
affaires étrangères du bahreïn qui est
aussi a pris la décision d'établir des
relations avec israël qui dit qui a dit
israël fait partie intégrante de
l'histoire de notre région
et quand vous prenez effectivement ce
recul à ce moment là vous avez une
capacité d'apaisement vous avez une
capacité de sagesse vous avez une
capacité de dialogue est donc ce qui se
passe avec les émirats arabes unis en
particulier est très intéressant surtout
après 13 années n'est ce pas de
gouvernance netanyahu
on aurait pu croire que donc une
radicalité israélienne très ancré à
droite influence des partis religieux et
bien allait bouleverser dans l'autre
sens le panorama de la région et bien
pas du tout les émirats arabes unis
y sont où est le pays le plus avancé en
termes de technologie en termes de
science en termes de priorité au
rationnel et l'a donc vous voyez on voit
des lignes de force qui se réunissent à
aussi très enclin à regarder les
processus sociétaux les émirats arabes
unis viennent de sélectionner une femme
astronaute n'est ce pas qui dans un an
va aller dans la station spatiale
internationale
donc on voit comme en israël la foi dans
la science la foi dont la pensée
rationnelle là on parle des émirats
arabes unis mais on l'a dit il ya les
égyptiens la jordan et il ya d'autres
pays également qui est qu'ils veulent
normaliser leurs relations avec israël
en tous les cas ça a été initiée sous le
mandat de donald trump
mais sans parler que des émirats arabes
unis ici parlons plus généralement du
monde arable gérard vespière quelle puce
à gagner dans ses relais dans l'allée
normalisation de ses relations
diplomatiques
alors vous avez évoqué l'histoire avec
la jordanie et l'egypte il ya aussi bien
sûr le maroc qui est en train de
normaliser ses taux qui a décidé de
normaliser ses relations aussi dont là
une volonté de dialogue et qui dit
dialogue dit apaisement est aussi
incitations pour l'autorité
palestinienne et bien de rentrer dans ce
jeu du rationnel de quitter le champ de
l'émotionnel de la libre et donc du
conflit et je crois que derrière ce
décor diplomatique qui s'élargit à bon
nombre de filles adula de la région donc
beaucoup de pays arabes à venir
probablement le koweit aussi donc il
bien se tenir et le chant du conflit
mais quelles conséquences au final pour
la région parce qu'on se souvient j'ai
quand même eu un
un gros affrontement ya pas très
longtemps onze jours de conflit qui a
fait 260 morts entre israël et le hamas
dernièrement alors je me référais à
nouveau à ce même ministre des affaires
étrangères du bahreïn qui a dit nous
avons un adversaire commun l'iran est
donc ce que vous venez d'évoquer ce
n'est pas tant le hamas qui a décidé ce
n'est pas le hamas qui s'est fabriqué
4160 troc être n'est ce pas elles sont
deux conceptions iranienne donc face
aussi un adversaire régional commun eh
bien vous avez une organisation
diplomatiques politiques des pays arabes
et d'israël qui est aussi est confronté
à l'iran mais qui a le plus à perdre au
final ce ne sont pas les palestiniens
quelle réaction de l'autorité
palestinienne à tout ça je pense pas
qu'il faille raisonner en termes de
pertes ce pas là la grande perte que
nous avons dans cette région c'est
l'absence de dialogue c'est l'absence de
bon sens a donc tout ce qui peut amener
et la relation diplomatique est la base
du dialogue et la base de l'analyse et
la base du bon sens et bien c'est un
plus à terme pour l'autorité
palestinienne qui doit s'éloigner
effectivement et qui s'éloignera si
l'iran ou le régime iranien périclite
progressivement
eh bien vous verrez le hamas aussi
péréclité progressivement et quelle
réaction de la communauté internationale
à ce jeu de normalisation des relations
entre israël et les pays arabes on a
l'impression que ça passe un peu au
second plan et que les médias en parlent
peu pourquoi fait qu'en france parce que
en france n'est ce pas les relations
internationales ne sont pas le fort de
notre pays en termes de médiatisation
il y a très peu de place dans les médias
en général à cette rubrique a donc mais
on ne peut que se réjouir de ce
processus qui va dans le sens de
l'histoire et qui devrait
progressivement avec le temps car on
vient de loin ne sais pas 1947 et bien
avec le temps à revenir vers
l'apaisement et une solution merci gérer
un vestiaire
voir répondu à nos questions je rappelle
que vous êtes spécialiste du
moyen-orient vous êtes chercheur associé
à la fée - la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient
vous êtes aussi le fondateur du site le
monde décrypté
après tout nous sommes un seul peuple
c'est par cette phrase que vladimir
poutine a conclu sa longue tribune
publiée ces dernières heures est
consacrée aux liens entre moscou et kiev
un texte qui intervient dans un contexte
de tensions internationales au sujet de
l'ukraine la correspondance en russie
signé verhaeghe hoffman
la russie n'a jamais été ne sera une en
tuk rennes et c'est aux citoyens
ukrainiens de décider ce que sera le
cren la demie routine a publié un
article détaillé en russe et un
ukrainien où il explique sa vision des
relations russo ukrainiennes dans le
texte intitulé au sujet de l'unité
historique des russes et des ukrainiens
il souligne que la russie est ouverte
dialogue avec son voisin est prête à
discuter des questions les plus
complexes je vous propose d'écouter au
cours des négociations officielles
surtout quand les partenaires
occidentaux les remettre à leur place
les représentants ukrainiens déclare de
temps à autres qui sont pleinement
attachés aux accords de minsk mais en
réalité se base sur leur hymne
acceptabilité ils n'ont pas l'intention
de discuter sérieusement ni du statut
particulier du donbass ni des garanties
pour les personnes qui y vivent
ils préfèrent exploiter une image de
victime d'une agression extérieure et
faire commerce de la russophobie la
russie est ouverte au dialogue avec
l'ukraine est prête à discuter des
questions les plus complexes mais il est
important pour nous de comprendre qu'un
partenaire défend ses intérêts nationaux
qu'il ne sert pas ceux de quelqu'un
d'autre qui n'est pas un outil dans les
mains de quelqu'un d'autre pour nous
combattre
après la publication de son article le
président russe a souhaité d'éclaircir
les raisons qui l'ont poussé à rédiger
ce texte
pour vladimir poutine c'est la phase
active du travail sur le projet anti
russie qui a suscité son inquiétude
écoutez pourquoi j'ai intensifié ce
travail précisément maintenant parce
qu'on assiste à l'émergence de
conditions qualitativement différente de
celle qui régnait encore tout récemment
visiblement la phase active du travail
sur le projet anti russie a commencé ce
qui bien sûr ne manque pas de susciter
chez nous une certaine inquiétude après
la parution de ce texte fait en outre
écho au projet de loi puis à la loi
ukrainienne sur les peuples autochtones
permettez moi de répéter une nouvelle
fois de quoi il s'agit le texte qualifie
les russes vivant dans les territoires
de la russie historique de peuples venus
de l'extérieur
et l'on commence de fait à les évincer
de ces territoires
voilà ce qui se passe et cela a
constitué l'un des éléments déclencheurs
de la parution de cet article
quant au président ukrainien wladimir
zelensky et il a affirmé qu'il donnerait
une réponse à l'article de vladimir
poutine
dès qu'il aurait le temps de lire le
texte dans son intégralité
ayant déjà lu quelques passages de
l'article il a reconnu que son homologue
russe avaient accompli un travail
approfondi mais a cependant regretté que
vladimir poutine ne trouve pas le temps
de le rencontrer et pour cet article
pour parler de cet article et du poids
des mots choisis par ce journaliste pas
comme les autres clubs blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir que le blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous sur air comptoir ce
qu'est ce qui a motivé selon vous
l'écriture de ses tribunes de vladimir
poutine et surtout à qui est ce qu elle
s'adresse je crois que le premier motif
c'est évidemment de resituer la relation
entre les ukrainiens et les russes dans
leur contexte historique dans le temps
long jeudi entre les ukrainiens et
russes puisque le titre de l'article
c'est le fait que les ukrainiennes et
russes constituent en fait un même
peuple
le deuxième motif c'est comme votre
sujet là la montre et de dénoncer un
projet anti russie ça c'est la thèse du
complot permanent contre la russie et
puis le troisième motif me semble-t-il
c'est que la dernière partie de
l'article laisse entrevoir des
possibilités de compromis si
naturellement les parties au conflit s'y
prête
et si les pays qu'ils sont les parrains
de l'accord de minsk poussent dans ce
sens alors à qui est destiné cet article
eh bien d'abord aux russes bien sûr
certainement et les russes sur dû
apprécier tous tes références
historiques que donne la lumière poutine
également la description de la grande
russie qui a subi beaucoup de
difficultés et deux revers c'est en
deuxième lieu les ukrainiens et
d'ailleurs il est traduit en ukrainien
pour signifier d'une part les lignes
rouges à ne pas franchir
vis-à-vis de la russie et d'autre part
pour dire que la solution du nom basse
elle est dans l'accord de minsk purement
et simplement
il n'y a qu'à appliquer l'accord de
minsk même si les dirigeants ukrainiens
en quelques réticences à aller dans ce
sens et puis les pays tiers évidemment
les pays tiers alors les pays tiers
ce qui est curieux c'est que ce cet
article qui était l'oncle et 22 pages
est publié sur le site du kremlin
depuis deux jours qu'ils étaient
traduits
le site du kremlin en anglais mais qui
n'est pas diffusée à la grande presse
internationale et que je pense que dans
les prochains jours ceci arrivera
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 14 juillet et
a très peu de journaux en france mais
dans la presse anglo saxonne on n'a pas
vu beaucoup d'écho à ce à ceux à cet
article à cette tribune du président de
la russie
et je pense que ça devrait venir dans
les prochains jours la difficulté c'est
qu'il est très long et que chacun
choisira les extraits qui qui lui qui
lui conviennent bien entendu que ce soit
en faveur de la russie en faveur de
l'ukraine pour aller vers une solution
pour créer des difficultés je pense
aussi que les historiens et et lé et les
ailés et les gens qui s'occupent de
stratégie vont se pencher avec beaucoup
d'intérêt sur ce texte inclut
blanchemaison ses tribunes est ce que
c'est une leçon d'histoire le chef du
kremlin utilise le passé pour expliquer
le présent quels faits historiques
relater ici vous ont le plus marqué oui
c'est une leçon d'histoire événementiel
ce n'est pas une leçon d'histoire au
sens des historiens qui décrivent les
grands mouvements sociaux économiques
qui font évoluer la situation dans le
monde mais c'est une histoire très
précises qui remonte au 9e siècle par
conséquent plus d'un millénaire avec des
détails extrêmement précis date et qui
sont destinés aux spécialistes et aux
russes qui connaissent parfaitement bien
leur histoire je crois que en effet dans
cette histoire on peut relever plusieurs
éléments d'abord des éléments étonnant
j'ai relevé en tout cas en lisant le
texte
au moins quatre critiques de l'époque
soviétique
la première est que la responsable
première responsabilité de ce qui est
arrivé ensuite dans la dans la
l'indépendance la prise d'indépendance
de l'ukraine et l'autre état et bien
c'est la constitution de 1924 c'est à
dire la constitution de lénine qui
prévoit que chaque république fédérative
peut reprendre son indépendance
lorsqu elles le désirent c'est une bombe
à retardement od poutine dans son texte
est en effet
la bombe a explosé en 1991 et puis il
dit aussi que les dirigeants veulent se
fixer le terme qu'il emploie ont
finalement flatter les différences entre
russes ukrainiens et biélorusses alors
qu'il s'agit fondamentalement et
culturellement d'un seul peuple
donc il pointe là aussi une
responsabilité et puis il dit ensuite
que son maître son mentor le premier
maire élu de saint pétersbourg
monsieur sobczak lui avait dit que
lorsque les pays ont pris leur
indépendance lorsque l'union soviétique
a écrêté est bien et il aurait fallu
revenir aux frontières d'avant les
traités de 1922
c'est à dire les traités console dès la
première guerre mondiale
alors évidemment quand on y regarde de
près ça veut dire que on aurait dû
garder en russie à la fédération de
russie
un certain nombre de territoires qui
sont partis ailleurs et puis et poutine
critique vertement la décision de
khrouchtchev de rattacher la crimée à
l'ukraine en 1954 et il dit même que
c'était tout à fait contraire aux règles
de droit international de l'époque alors
c'est difficile de démontrer exactement
si c'était contraire aux droits de rack
de leur international mais il est vrai
que l'ukraine avait une voix à l'onu
comme la biélorussie à l'époque de
l'union soviétique c'était les
arrangements de 1945 et que peut-être
que ce rattachement en effet parcours
fait par khrouchtchev a été un peu hâtif
en tout cas générateur de problèmes dans
l'avenir et puis poutine dans cet arc
dans cet article très long mentionne le
prix réduit qui a été fait à l'ukraine
pendant très longtemps pour la
fourniture de gaz russe et dit pendant
les trois premières années
d'indépendance de l'ukraine ceci a été
dans le fond à un avantage financier
d'environ 85 milliards de dollars ce qui
est énorme
ensuite il décrit une économie qui
craignent elles qui c'est d'éviter qui a
perdu en 30 ans à peu près la moitié de
sa capacité industrielle et qui en effet
ne fait que se déliter en se mettant
dans le fond à la merci du fonds
monétaire international alors il conclut
ce passage en disant que la russie a
toujours été favorable à une coopération
technique et économique avec le cred et
qu'elle le reste
et qu'elle le reste c'est un point tout
à fait tout à fait ouverts voilà donc
les livres et des jeux divers points qui
m'ont frappé dans la lecture de ce texte
qui est en effet très intéressant et
qu'il faut étudier
dernière question que de l'en mélenchon
suite à cet article à cette publication
quel avenir selon vous pour les rays les
relations russo ukrainiennes
on peut noter que la lumière poutine
dans ce texte regrette que les
dirigeants ukrainiens réécrivent
l'histoire qu'il attribue la famine des
années 30 à une volonté de génocide de
la part de moscou que il essaie
d'effacer la contribution d'un certain
nombre d'ukrainiens à la deuxième guerre
mondiale
il dit même je crois que 2000 ukrainiens
sont des héros de l'union soviétique et
que tout ça est effacée aujourd'hui dans
l'histoire ukrainienne
il dit aussi que le gouvernement
ukrainien l'élite ukrainienne tourner le
dos à la russie pour se tourner vers
l'occident et qu'elle rêve finalement
d'une entrée à l'otan évidemment à
laquelle la russie est tout à fait
opposés et poutine l'a dit d'ailleurs à
joe biden à genève il ya quelques
semaines je note aussi que dans ce texte
vladimir poutine ne critique à aucun
moment directement l'union européenne
est dit simplement qu'en 2013
la russie avait proposé une concertation
comme cela se fait d'habitude avec les
pays qui ont des flux
important l'union européenne voulait
conclure un accord de coopération voire
d'association avec l'ukraine la russie
demande à être consultés et l'union
européenne refusent cette consultation
et par conséquent n'a pas tenu compte
des flux économiques existant entre la
russie et l'ukraine
c'est dommage peut-être que cette voie
reste ouverte et en effet et
parallèlement aux accords de mise qui
sont la solution pour le nom basse
peut-être poutine ou voit-il la voie à
une négociation économique ou à des
consultations économique en tout cas sur
l'avenir économique de l'ukraine dans
son ensemble qui intéresse naturellement
l'union européenne mais aussi la russie
et sur la reconstruction
il faudra bien prévoir un jour du
donbass de ces deux provinces qui ont
été largement détruite par la guerre
donc là on voit peut-être des pistes il
faut exploiter et peut-être que vladimir
poutine a tant que l'union européenne
plutôt que de prendre ce texte à la
légère prennent les points
ils sont positifs ou qui peuvent être
interprétées comme positif pour aller de
l'avant
merci que dans une maison pour votre
analyse
par rapport donc à ce texte publié par
par vladimir poutine je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales feu vert aujourd'hui de
la banque centrale européenne pour
lancer une première phase en vue de
créer u11 auront symbolique cette
monnaie digital pourra devenir un moyen
de paiement en 2025 objectifs notamment
concurrencer les crypto monnaie comme le
bitcoin hélène vasculaires le but de nos
travaux et de veiller à ce qu'à l'ère
numérique les ménages et les entreprises
est toujours accès à la forme de monnaie
la plus sûre la monnaie de la banque
centrale depuis cinq ans l'union
européenne et du guil et monnaie
numérique un moyen de se positionner
face à l'explosion des paiements
dématérialisés qui s'est amplifiée avec
la pandémie de qovu de 19 la banque
centrale européenne redoutent que cet
engouement profita des monnaies
virtuelles privés ou à des devises
étrangères en 2019
le projet de facebook visant à créer une
monnaie virtuelle le libre a désormais
appeler le diem a causé un électrochoc
l'euro numérique serait l'équivalent des
billets en euros mais sous forme
dématérialisée
tout comme une pièce physique cette
monnaie virtuelle seraient émises par la
banque centrale européenne est
accessible aux ménages comme aux
entreprises
l'euro numérique existerait
parallèlement aux espèces sans les
remplacer un mode de paiement
alternatifs contribuant à l'inclusion
financière selon la bce moyens de
paiement officielle avec une unité de
compte déterminé par la bce l'euro
numérique promet d'être plus stable
qu'une crypto monnaie dont le cours est
très volatile une des limites de 7 euros
virtuels et qu'il ne pourrait pas
garantir l'anonymat à ses utilisateurs
pour des raisons de sécurité afin de
prévenir les risques de fraude fiscale
ou de financement d'activités illicites
l'un des défis pour la bce prévenir les
risques de pertes en cas d'accident
informatique ou de cyber attaques
ce système de paiement pourraient se
trouver confrontées à l'illettrisme
technologiques et aux inégalités liées à
son accès entraînant une fracture
numérique
une cassure qui s'est fortement fait
ressentir notamment au début de
l'épidémie de kobe de 19
des pays comme la chine ou les
etats-unis travaillent aussi à
l'émission de leur propre crypto monnaie
pékin tests déjà depuis le mois de mars
le paiement par ios via smartphone avec
l'ambition d'en faire une monnaie
internationale de référence capable de
faire concurrence au dollar restait sur
arte france on se retrouve à 21h pour
évoquer les manifestations contre
l'extension du pass sanitaires et la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants du
conseil constitutionnel va d'ailleurs se
pencher sur la question d'une éventuelle
censure
et puis gros plan sur la situation
sanitaire alarmante en tunisie où
plusieurs élus montent au créneau pour
dénoncer l'inaction du gouvernement face
à la propagation du variant delta du
comité 19 a tout de suite
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses les chiffres qui sont
avancés et qui sont montrés au
d'analyser l'information de ce mercredi
14 juillet on continue de questionner
nos invités tout de suite c'est des
titres nombreuses manifestations partout
en france cet après midi pour des
lancers l'extension du pass sanitaire
annoncée lundi soir par emmanuel macron
une mesure contestée par des
associations de défense des libertés et
qui divise juridiquement au coeur du
débat le complexe équilibre entre droit
à la santé et libertés publiques
[Musique]
presque un an après l explosion du port
de beyrouth le premier ministre désigné
saad hariri a présenté au président du
liban une mouture de son nouveau
gouvernement
une équipe dirigeante de 24 spécialistes
conformément à l'initiative française
une annonce qui intervient alors que le
pays du cèdre est confronté à de
multiples crises
[Musique]
le pentagone où commencera fin juillet à
évacuer les afghans qu'ils n'ont aidé
annonce tout à l'heure d'un haut
responsable gouvernemental américain
washington prévoit de boucler son
retrait d'afghanistan le 31 août après
vingt ans de guerre alors que les
talibans ne cesse de gagner du terrain
paris appelle de son côté ses
ressortissants à quitter kaboul bien
rentrer en france
[Musique]
17000 personnes mobilisés partout en
france en ce jour de fête nationale des
rassemblements pour dénoncer à
l'extension du pass sanitaire annoncée
lundi soir par emmanuel macron du côté
de paris deux mille deux cent cinquante
personnes présentes pour un cortège non
déclarés à noter des heurts avec les
forces de l'ordre notamment du côté de
la place de la république dans la
capitale et puis place bellecour aussi à
lyon un retour sur cette journée de
mobilisation sous tension avec kim rossi
et jordi demory il ya eu un deuxième 14
juillet aujourd'hui celui des opposants
au pass sanitaires on a pu compter des
manifestations dans toute la france à
perpignan à lyon où on a noté plusieurs
débordements à nantes ou encore à annecy
annecy où un groupe de manifestants est
entré dans la cour de la préfecture de
haute-savoie où ils sont restés environ
une heure trente avant de s'en aller
d'eux mêmes sans intervention des forces
de l'ordre une action qui a tout de même
été vivement condamnée par le ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin sur
twitter est ici à paris le rassemblement
a donné lieu à quelques échauffourées
deux cortèges se sont rejoints boulevard
magenta avant de se scinder en deux
groupes un groupe est revenu ici place
de la république et l'autre à jouer au
chat et à la souris avec les forces de
l'ordre dans tout le nord du 10e
arrondissement en incendiant au passage
quelques poubelles et en dressant des
barricades afin de retarder
l'intervention des motards de la brave
et des forces de sécurisation et
d'intervention
on a pu noter de nombreux jets de
projectiles ainsi que des containers à
verre renversé les manifestants et les
black blocks qui se sont ensuite
dispersés avant de retourner pour
certains ici place de la république à
paris
à noter qu'une nouvelle manifestation
est d'ores et déjà prévue ce samedi
l'extension du pass sanitaire contesté
donc dans les rues aujourd'hui en cas de
manquement aux futures obligations de
contrôle un exploitant sera passible
d'un an de prison et d'une amende
pouvant aller jusqu'à 45 mille euros le
texte précise également que toute
personne contaminée devra respecter un
isolement de dix jours le projet de loi
doit être examiné par l'assemblée
nationale la semaine prochaine et fait
déjà débat notamment sur sa
constitutionnalité
david qualifie le conseil d'état dont on
estime les origines au moyen-âge à deux
rôles précis d'abord conseiller le
gouvernement pour la préparation des
projets de loi ou décret mais il est
surtout le juge suprême administrative
qui tranche les litiges relatifs aux
actes et des administrations
l'extension du pas salutaire on fait
partie l'institution doit à se prononcer
sur sa légalité
déjà contesté il ya un mois par une
association de la défense des libertés
estimant que le dispositif divulgue de
façon injustifiée à des données
personnelles
le recours a été rejeté le 6 juillet
dernier compte rendu du jugement est
plutôt clair le juge des référés relève
que ce dispositif papier ou numérique
n'est pas requis pour les activités du
quotidien ou l'exercice de certaines
libertés fondamentales manifestations
réunions exercice du culte
le juge des référés estime que le pass
sanitaire ne porte pas une atteinte
grave
et à part des smartphones est tout de
suite capté et son image est une image
qui doit être en permanence contrôler et
les hommes politiques les femmes
politiques sont finalement des femmes et
des hommes donc tout le monde qui
peuvent être soumis par moments à des
moments de relâchement mais en effet eux
ils n'ont pas le droit de se relâcher en
principe dernière question très
rapidement il ne reste plus beaucoup de
temps a nominé des thierno sur jérôme
simplement directeur général de la santé
qui va quitter prochainement son poste
pour d'autres fonctions
selon nos confrères de france info
auprès du cully cette information auprès
du ministère de la santé et qui ont
confirmé donc une information de paris
match
votre réaction c'est un fusible qui
saute dans toute cette communication
encore une fois sur la crise du coni
alors oui est ce que c'est un fusible
qui saute je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr
parce que bon jérôme salomon était dans
ce poste depuis maintenant un certain
nombre d'années ici il avait été
utilisée comme fusible il y avait 120
moment ce et là des moments plus
critique de cette crise
mais c'est vraisemblablement aussi la
possibilité le moyen pour l'exécutif de
se séparer d'un haut fonctionnaire qui
sera vraisemblablement un promu à
d'autres fonctions et de faire
apparaître une nouvelle tête à la
direction générale de la santé dans un
moment qui reste extrêmement critique
sur le plan de la crise sanitaire
merci à renommer les métiers d'avoir
répondu à une version est d'avoir
décrypter donc toute cette communication
gouvernementale vous êtes que
spécialiste en communication et
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire
si la crise sanitaire fait donc parler
en france la tunisie évoque quant à elle
via son ministre de la santé
l'effondrement du système sanitaire des
élus pointent du doigt l'inaction du
gouvernement
certains mais remonte même au créneau
illustration avec walid la mairie qui
reproche à l'agencé régionale de santé
de minimiser la gravité de la situation
dans sa commune reportage sur place s'il
bat sam shemie et un nasri séquelles ça
à 50 km au nord-est de tunis semble
figée dans le temps
loin de l'agitation de la capitale dans
cette ville à la fois cotchery agricole
la recrudescence des cas positifs au
colis de 19 est venue perturber le
quotidien des agriculteurs notamment le
maire un édile qui n'a pas hésité à
monter au créneau pour dénoncer
l'inaction du gouvernement et
l'appréciation à la baisse que ce
dernier a fait de la situation sanitaire
de sa commune ici attaqué le ca nous
sommes la plus grande commune du
gouvernorat de nabeul avec 25000
habitants
la situation ici est catastrophique les
chiffres que nous annoncent nos médecins
locaux sont loin d'être ceux publiés par
l' agence régionale de santé qui chaque
jour annonce des chiffres différents
hier 0 aujourd'hui 1 avant-hier 8
les chiffres que nous avons ici dépasse
les 2000 cas positifs depuis quelques
semaines ce virus est en train de se
propager très vite
nous voulons connaître la cause et
surtout savoir pourquoi la rs publie des
chiffres erronés
désemparé il a l'impression de mener ce
combat seul face à une population peu
consciente du danger des forces de
l'ordre aux abonnés absents et un
gouvernement qui semble ne pas vouloir
prendre ses responsabilités nous tentons
au maximum de sensibiliser la population
sur le port du masque d'éviter les
rassemblements notamment dans les cafés
mais cette mission ne peut pas être
menée par le maire seul chacun doit
prendre ses responsabilités à commencer
par les autorités la police par exemple
pourrait punir ceux qui ne porte pas de
masque
tout le monde doit être responsable et
l' agence régionale de santé doit nous
communiquer les chiffres exacts
pour que nous puissions agir en
conséquence et prendre des mesures
sévères et ferment chaque jour il fait
le point avec les quatre médecins de la
ville afin d'évaluer la situation en
temps réel
voici l'un des quatre cabinets médicaux
de la commune tous ouverts de 8h à 22h
car nous sommes dépourvus d'hôpitaux
dans le coin excusez une seconde s'il
vous plaît à l'eau très bien j'arrive
tout de suite je suis désolé on vient de
m'annoncer deux morts supplémentaires
je dois me rendre à la mairie pour
signaler les actes de décès les halons
de décès sont quasiment devenues
quotidiennes dans cette agglomération
agricole quelle impression d'avoir été
oubliés par tunis à seulement une heure
de route
malgré cette situation il faut continuer
de sauver des vies c'est la mission que
s'est confiée rihab bel haj salah l'un
des quatre généralistes de tekel ça un
travail devenu pénible par manque de
moyens alors que son cabinet ne
désemplit pas en 1 seulement c'est une
situation catastrophique
attaquez-les ça c'est une situation
catastrophique demandez moi pourquoi
simplement cats à quel saint nous avons
beaucoup de cas sous-estimer les gens
sont en train de mourir les gens meurent
tout simplement pourquoi par défaut de
moyens on manque de tests rapides de
tests pcr je suis à 45 cas par jour
c'est affreux si je dois me débrouiller
tout seul comme c'est le cas pour mes
collègues au moins et des nous ne nous
laissez pas comme ça donnez nous des
concentrateurs à 10 litres et nous nous
débrouillerons la mort est devenu le
quotidien de cette ville dont le
cimetière est devenu plus fréquentés
qu'à l'accoutumée au grand dam du maire
nous sommes ici au cimetière de tackels
ça où nous sommes rendus aujourd'hui
enterré des gens tous les jours à cause
de ce qu vite
hier les autorités parlaient d'un cas
positif alors que le même jour
nous avons eu deux décès des chiffres
erronés une ville sinistrée
le cas de tekel ça est loin d'être une
exception dans un pays où médecins
associations et citoyens tire la
sonnette d'alarmé face à un système de
santé à l'agonie et un gouvernement qui
semble avoir perdu le contrôle de la
situation
comme walid amiri de plus en plus de
mères n'hésitent plus à monter au
créneau pour que le pouvoir tunisien
prenne enfin ses responsabilités et on
dirait que dans cette édition ryan
chebbi président de l'association pour
la promotion de la coopération et de
l'amitié entre la france et la tunisie
bonsoir hayat chaibi merci d'être avec
nous sur arte france ce soir bonsoir
vous êtes en france mais quand vous
voyez ce reportage de bastien chebbi est
désert nasri qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque de la colère et de la tristesse
de la colère parce que on voit bien que
la situation est incontrôlable qu'il
n'est pas en mesure d'être maîtrisés
malheureusement et de la tristesse parce
que c'est il n'y a pas de mots pour
décrire ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
tunisie on coûte près de 100 morts par
jour je dis bien 100 morts par jour dans
un pays qui compte 11 millions
d'habitants c'est à dire l'équivalent
population de la région ile-de-france
donc de la colère et de la tristesse
mais je veux croire qu'il reste encore
quelque chose de possible et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la mobilisation de
toutes et tous de la diaspora de la
communauté internationale est plus que
nécessaire
et justement la tunisie qui appelle à
l'aide sa diaspora de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée concrètement comment les
tunisiens de france peuvent-ils aider
tunis sachant que la france a placé hier
à la tunisie sur sa liste rouge des pays
à risque whisky ce qui en soi est
logique un compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire
mais moi je voudrais surtout parler des
actions qui sont mises en place
aujourd'hui par la diaspora cette
richesse tunisienne de l'étranger comme
j'aime à les appeler qui se mobilisent
partout sur le territoire français du
nord au sud de l'est à l'ouest pour
aider les tunisiennes et les tunisiens
avec le concours des autorités
tunisiennes puisque sur instruction du
président de la république qui
assaillent aide les autorités
tunisiennes ont été mis à profit
l'ambassade de la république tunisienne
des 10
les rencontres suis là pour récolter le
matériel médical et l'acheminer dans les
plus brefs délais en tunisie à travers
la direction
la direction d comme on dirige de la
santé militaire pardon qui acheminera
directement le matériel en tunisie et
donc pour le coup avec notre association
par exemple nous organisons dès samedi
une collecte d'équipements médicaux à
noisy-le-grand à la salle jean-moulin à
livry gargan
et puis comment dirais-je à epinay sur
seine à la maison des associations et
pour récolter ce matériel médical et
l'acheminer dans les plus brefs délais
en tunisie donc là c'est le tissu
associatif qui travaillent mais on sait
qu'il ya aussi un manque de vaccins la
france va fournir dans les semaines à
venir plus d'un million de doses
le maroc également annoncé l'envoi d'une
aide médicale d'urgence la solidarité
c'est ce qui peut donner un peu de répit
à la tunisie bah c'est un bol d'oxygène
on l'a bien vu et vous la voulez bien
vous le devenez de l'évoquer la tunisie
va recevoir une aide importante de la
france plus d'un million de vaccins
comme celle de l'arabie saoudite qui va
envoyer un million de vaccins l'algérie
également envoyé du matériel médical et
d'oxygène le maroc la mauritanie la
turquie l'egypte la môme la colle à la
communauté internationale se mobilise
donc forcément ça va donner un bol
d'oxygène à la tunisie est elle en a
bien besoin et on va continuer à être à
ses côtés pour essayer en tout cas de de
freiner l'épidémie
vous avez évoqué ce mot je voulais vous
revenir dessus
la communauté internationale qui se
mobilisent vous avez parlé du tissu
associatif mais quel rôle concret de la
communauté internationale est ce qu'elle
peut aller suffisamment loin quand on
voit tout ce qui se passe déjà dans les
problèmes inhérents dans les pays
10 avancé à ce que les pays riches on
l'a vu avec le système kovacs qui est
difficile à mettre en place un peu
partout est ce que est ce que les pays
riches
ce souci véritablement des pays plus en
difficulté comme la tunisie écoutez en
tout cas la france s'agissant de la
france elle elle prend sa part de
responsabilité mais on peut toujours
faire plus l'union européenne par
exemple peut faire plus peut mobiliser
un certain nombre de pays de l'union
européenne pour envoyer du matériel
médical et des vaccins bien évidemment
la tunisie est le pays le plus frappé
par la crise sanitaire le plus frappé
d'afrique mais également du monde arabe
il faut faire plus et naturellement que
dans le cas du dispositif kovacs il ya
une nécessité d'accroître l'aide à la
tunisie parce qu'on le voit bien la
tunisie est en train
comment dirais-je de sombrer dans cette
crise sanitaire
il faut également être à ses côtés et
donc dans cette danse est dans cet
épisode que nous sommes en train de
vivre
l'union européenne partenaire important
de la tunisie doit prendre toute sa
place et toutes ses responsabilités aux
côtés de la france pour aider la tunisie
et faire en sorte qu'elles sortent au
moins en tout cas par le haut si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi de cette crise merci
riad à chaque billet d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le présidentialisation pour la promotion
de la coopération et de l'amitié entre
la france et la tunisie restait sur la
stèle france dans quelques instants en
direction le liban où le premier
ministre désigné vient de présenter une
équipe dirigeante alors qu'une
manifestation à beyrouth a eu lieu
récemment devant la résidence du
ministre de l'intérieur mohammed famille
qui zoome sur l'afghanistan des talibans
affirme contrôler désormais 85% du
territoire de nombreux civils tentent de
fuir
la france elle appelle ses
ressortissants à quitter le pays
[Musique]
donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une des plus importantes
compagnies de taxis en france l'activité
a repris sdap elmander paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour là l'avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
d'aller à cuba 5 6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivée la
concurrente bb&t gros gros choc d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé les 20000 à
45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
[Musique]
très heureux de vous retrouver sur arte
france il est 21h30 heure française il
est 22h30 au liban où le premier
ministre désigné saad hariri a présenté
tout à l'heure au président michel aoun
d'une mouture de son nouveau
gouvernement
une équipe dirigeante qui sera composé
de 24 spécialiste je cite conformément à
l'initiative française et à celle du
président du parlement selon les mots de
celui qui a dirigé le pays du cèdre à
trois reprises
saad hariri dit vouloir commencer à
travailler sérieusement pour arrêter je
cite l'effondrement le liban est
confrontée à l'une des pires crises
économiques au monde depuis 1850 selon
la banque mondiale
cette annonce intervient alors qu hier
des centaines de familles ont manifesté
à beyrouth presque un an après la
terrible explosion du port de la
capitale libanaise
un rassemblement devant la résidence
d'un ministre accusé de bloquer
l'enquète ou à l'est de ben ali
[Applaudissements]
un cercueil en bois qui se décompose
devant l'entrée de l'immeuble où loge le
ministre de l'intérieur tout un symbole
pour illustrer la frustration d'un
peuple en quête de réponses plus de onze
mois après l'explosion meurtrière dans
le port de beyrouth l'enquète stagne et
les responsables tarde à être désignée
désarroi colère les émotions sont
décuplées au sein de la capitale
les familles des victimes veulent la
justice pour leurs enfants et leurs
familles
comment sont elles censées obtenir
justice si le ministre de l'intérieur se
cacher ne fait pas son travail
correctement qui va compenser leurs
pertes pourquoi ne vient-il pas parler
pourquoi ne fait-il pas ce qui est juste
l'explosion a eu lieu il ya presque un
an
où est la justice l mardi 13 juillet
marqué par le cri de désespoir de
centaines de libanais certains en
sanglantes et d'autres perdant
connaissance
une journée également marquée par le son
des gaz lacrymogènes police et
population se sont affrontés dans un
climat de ras-le-bol
les revendications sociales ayant
rejoint la colère des familles de
victimes
nous sommes dans un pays où il n'ya pas
de carburant pas d'avenir pas
d'éducation pas d'eau pas d'électricité
il n'y a rien ils nous ont tués dans
l'explosion du port ils nous ont tués
ils ont tué des gens et nous ont tous
fait vivre dans la terreur plus de 200
morts six cent mille blessés et des
quartiers totalement dévastés le 4 août
2000 vent a laissé des traces
le ministre libanais de l'intérieur par
intérim mohamed fahmi a accusé
d'ingérence
ce dernier a refusé notamment la demande
du juge principal de l'enquète
d'auditionner le chef de la direction
générale de la sécurité générale
le compte à rebours a donc commencé pour
les autorités libanaises appelé par la
france et l'union européenne à faire
preuve de plus de responsabilité dans la
reconstruction du pays
en effet le pays du cèdre est à genoux
plonger dans l'une des pires crises
économiques au monde depuis le milieu du
19e siècle selon la banque mondiale lieu
qui prépare actuellement des sanctions
ciblées contre les responsables de ce
marasme libanais et pour parler du liban
françois el bacha en direct de beyrouth
il est économiste et fondateur du site
d'information libnanews
bonsoir françois lebas un merci de
répondre à nos questions vous êtes donc
à beyrouth
quelle est l'ambiance ce soir à ce qu'il
ya de nouvelles manifestations bien ce
que c'est un calme précaire qui règne
dans les rues de la capitale libanaise
des manifestations il y en a toujours
bonsoir tout d'abord les manifestations
comme je disais on a toujours
aujourd'hui il ya une manifestation à
nouveau des familles des victimes de
l'explosion du port de beyrouth devant
le tribunal devant le palais de justice
de la ville
donc c'est un mouvement qui est continu
il ya des manifestations aussi en raison
de la dégradation des conditions
sociales et économiques de la crise que
traverse ce pays donc il n'ya pas de
raison pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
manifestation aujourd'hui
saad hariri a présenté tout à l'heure
une équipe dirigeante à michel à
conforme le site à l'initiative de paris
selon ses mots véritable changement ou
bien on prend les mêmes et on recommence
pour le moment il ya peu d'informations
qui circulent concernant la composition
exacte de ce gouvernement donc on est
dans l'inconnu
on peut pas dire qu est ce de quoi il
s'agit on nous fait dire que ce
gouvernement est composé de 24 membres
on connaît donc grosso modo les grandes
lignes dans le quatre ans pas un tiers à
la présidence à un tiers au premier
ministre et un tiers au hezbollah et
amal mais ça ne répond pas à une des
questions fondamentales qui était à
l'origine du blocage c'est-à-dire que ce
gouvernement en fin de compte
contredirait selon la présidence la
république
le pacte national qui est lui stipule
une composition à 50 sous 50 50 entre
communautés chrétienne et communauté
musulmane
donc on verra bien difficile donc de
voir l'avenir politiquement on vous aura
très certainement pour décrypter un
petit peu plus tard quand on aura la
composition exacte de ce gouvernement
composé de 24 spécialiste donc le 4 août
marquera le premier anniversaire triste
anniversaire de l'explosion du port de
beyrouth
l'enquète y étiez dont la vue sur le
sujet doit y ait de bennani il ya des
manifestations qui ont eu lieu en la
digue devant la résidence d'un ministre
qui a accusé de bloquer des
investigations est ce qu'un jour on
connaîtra véritablement la fin mot de
l'histoire
le fin mot de l'histoire pour le moment
c'est que le port de beyrouth c'était
une zone où tous les partis c'était un
c'est une sorte de gagne pain tous les
partis donc ils sont tous impliqués
dedans et c'est très difficile et c'est
très difficile ce sera très difficile
d'avoir la vérité pleine et entière le
nul on a des personnalités qui sont
proches du président de la chambre qui
sont impliqués dessus on a des
personnalités qui n'ont par exemple son
bras droit directement commencer un
ministre des finances qui est drôle dont
l'immunité est également demandé la
levée de l'immunité est également
demandé pardon par le juge
on a une tête des personnalités proches
de saad hariri le premier ministre
désigné qui sont impliqués de sedan dont
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur n'aura
de machenaud et le directeur à l'époque
de l'explosion du port de beyrouth
hassan corail tél donc c'est un dossier
potentiellement explosif pour tout le
monde et vu l'état dans lequel est là la
justice libanaise qui est très politisée
on peut se poser beaucoup de questions
sur le résultat au final et on a vu ce
que cela donne par exemple concernant
les dossiers d'assassinats qu'on a vu
ces dernières années et même avant le
tribunal spécial pour le liban a
accouché d'une souris
comment les libanais
vive t-il concrètement parce que d'après
ulysse l'unicef 50% des libanais vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté et 30% des
enfants sautent un repas par jour la
situation est ce qu'elle peut encore
s'aggraver ou est-ce qu'il ya peut-être
de l'espoir avec ce gouvernement donc
présenté tout à l'heure par par saad
hariri
dans quel état d'esprit est ce que vous
êtes vous françois lebas chat je pense
qu'on arrive aujourd'hui au creux de la
vague en fait donc je vois pas qu'est ce
qui pourrait encore être pire on a eu
une bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui parce que
le fonds monétaire international va
verser d'ici demain à 860 millions de
dollars au liban de droits de tirage
spéciaux donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça va permettre un peu de
gagner du temps mais on a toujours un
creux de gros problèmes qui sont liés
aux 7 au secteur bancaire les réserves
monétaires de la banque centrale
disponibles sont pratiquement vides
on a une dévaluation de facto de la
libanaise puisque c'est elle la parité
au marché noir qui nie qui prévaut
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de choses
dans le marché noir qui sont non
rationnels en fait la parité réelle
aujourd'hui est supérieur à est
supérieur pour la libanaise par rapport
à priori à la parité du marché noir
donc est-ce que ses 860 millions de
dollars qui sont attendus ne vont pas
améliorer déjà un peu là la valeur de la
ligue libanais c'est donc regagné un peu
de pouvoir d'achat il faut quand même
préciser que la libanaise a perdu 92
pour cent de sa valeur par rapport au
dollar et que aujourd'hui le salaire
minimum ses 30 dollars et le salaire
médian c'est à dire la moitié des gens
reçoit à peu près 114 dollars soit
environ 3 dollars 3 dollars ou moins par
jour
merci françois el bacha pour
pour ces explications ces mots forts que
vous prononcez je rappelle que vous êtes
en direct de beyrouth vous êtes
économiste et fondateur du site
d'information libnanews
je remercie plus de 300 afghans ont fui
au tadjikistan voisin selon une agence
de presse officielle locale en cause
l'inexorable avancée des talibans qui se
poursuit après deux mois d'offensive
contre les forces afghanes et talibans
disent
ce matin s'être emparé d'un poste
frontière clés à kandahar dans le sud du
pays une information rapidement démentie
par qui roule dans nord les insurgés
islamistes ont encerclé les capitales
provinciales et menace désormais d'un
blocus la situation sur place
inquiète la communauté internationale
dont la france paris a rapatrié samedi
ses ressortissantes en affrétant un
avion des centaines de familles sont
contraintes de fuir leurs maisons pour
des camps de réfugiés
amaya soubelet avec anthony juillet les
familles afghanes contraintes de fuir
face à l'avancée des talibans qui
s'intensifie de jour en jour les
conditions de vie misérables et
dangereuse pour ses habitants déplacés
dans des camps pour tenter de survivre
j'ai dû me séparer de mes fils dans les
conflits mais mon fils aîné a été tué
mes autres enfants sont en train de
vivre là bas nous avons juste sauvé nos
vies et je n'ai rien apporté avec moi
pour manger j'ai demandé de l'aide
nous avons demandé un soutien pour nous
tous c'est mon frère là bas il a été
déplacé aussi les enfants orphelins sont
ceux de mon fils et nous n'avons pas
d'abri les combats entre talibans et
forces afghanes nous font qu'augmenter
le nombre de déplacés à prendre en
charge le service chargé des immigrants
à kandahar fournit aux victimes à toi
ainsi que des denrées vitales
[Musique]
selon l'ordre direct du gouverneur de
kandahar et du chef du bureau des
affaires des immigrants ils sont prêts à
coopérer tout d'abord avec les familles
qui n'ont pas d'abri pour elle nous
préparons des abris dans les différentes
parties de la ville y compris des
installations pour faciliter l'accès à
l'eau la nourriture l'électricité et la
vaisselle et camps de déplacés sont donc
le seul espoir de ces centaines de
familles pour certaines d'entre elles
l'accès à la nourriture et à l'eau et
rendus impossibles pendant plusieurs
jours à cause des bombardements talibans
à kaboul ces mêmes bombardements ont tué
quatre civils et blessé 11 autres selon
le porte parole de la police de la
capitale les habitants vivent le drame
aux premières loges j'étais assis ici
puis soudain une explosion a eu lieu
j'ai tourné mon visage vers l'endroit
d'où ça venait j'ai vu de la poussière
s'est levé et j'ai couru pour aider les
gens j'ai vu mon ami qui était là il
avait perdu ses jambes
[Musique]
l'explosion qui a eu lieu dans le centre
de la capitale n'a pas été revendiqué le
pays plongé dans la violence subie
l'avancé talibane qui dit désormais
posséder 85% du territoire et menaces
des points hautement stratégique comme
des postes frontière avec le pakistan où
le tadjikistan et pour évoquer cette
situation chaotique en afghanistan le
général dominique trinquant ancien chef
de la mission militaire française à
l'onu bonsoir dominique trinquant merci
de répondre à nos questions plus de 300
afghans qui se réfugie au tadjikistan
alors que les talibans disent contrôler
près de 85% du territoire s'est avancée
des insurgés islamistes
elle est inéluctable est ce que c'est
une question de jours pour qu'il
reprenne totalement le pays ils
n'éduquent table je ne sais pas mais
prévisible très certainement si vous
voulez l'afghanistan est en guerre
depuis longtemps les américains depuis
20 ans avant les russes personne n'a
réussi vraiment à pacifier ce pays et
pour ne parler que des 20 dernières
années
les stratégies se sont succédé sans
vraiment avoir une adhésion complète des
afghans donc les talibans qui était
qu'ils avaient été repoussés très
initialement il ya 20 ans il avait été
battu et bien ont repris le dessus et
aujourd'hui il ya deux options les
talibans réussissent à conquérir tout le
pays
c'est une option
ou bien la guerre continue entre
différentes factions en afghanistan mais
je vois difficilement d'autres options
le pentagone dit avoir rapatrie 90% de
ses troupes
idem pour londres les afghans qui ont
aidé washington vont être évacués par
avion par les états unis fin juillet les
rares les rats quittent le navire mais
mais quelles conséquences pour la
population veut non mais vous avez
raison la population et a maintenant
comme comme solution soit dans la
deuxième option je disais je signalais
de combattre contre les talibans avec
des factions soit ceux de se soumettre à
la dictature des talibans une fois
qu'elle sera installé c'est très triste
pour les populations afghanes
mais ceci illustre bien le fait qu'on ne
peut pas apporter une solution un pays
en venant de l'extérieur
la solution doit venir du pays lui-même
et il est vrai que l'afghanistan est un
pays qui est particulièrement compliquée
à pacifier de l'intérieur mais quel
avenir alors pour l'afghanistan et
quelles conséquences pour la région
est ce que des pays voisins comme le
tadjikistan comme le pakistan et qui
peuvent être inquiétés par les talibans
ce qui me dit avoir un risque
d'embrasement de la région écoutez
toutes ces régions que vous citez sont
très très proches effectivement de
l'afghanistan pour ne citer que le
pakistan la zone qu'on appelle la zone
frontalière
la zone tribale qui est avant la
frontière
exact du pakistan est une zone
extrêmement perméable avec l'afghanistan
c'est d'ailleurs là qu'on avait
découvert monsieur oussama ben laden
donc on voit bien qu'il ya une porosité
qui fait que la menace peut s'étendre
maintenant je pense que les talibans ont
une visée plus local plus visées sur
l'afghanistan et donc je pense qu'il ya
peu de chances pour que cela s'étende
au-delà de l'afghanistan en revanche la
menace qu on peut craindre c'est une
menace de dissémination du terrorisme
est-ce que les talibans vont être des
sponsors d'un certain nombre de
mouvements de terreau et c'est ça qui
nous intéresse nous pour la sécurité de
vos pays
vingt ans de guerre 2000 milliards de
dollars soit dix fois plus que la
première guerre mondiale pour qui pour
quoi pour rien
il ya georgia bol du bush qui a parlé ce
matin lui qui avait envoyé un tout tout
ses troupes américaines en afghanistan
il a critiqué le retrait des troupes
américaines
oui le critiquer le retrait des troupes
américaines qui est la conséquence de la
décision qu'il a pris initialement
il faut se rappeler que lorsque nous
sommes intervenus et jeudi nous parce
que les français se sont joints très
rapidement à l'opération américaine
le but c'était de retrouver monsieur
oussama ben laden il avait été demandé
aux talibans de le livrer ils ont refusé
de le livrer et donc il ya eu un moment
à ce moment là une invasion américaine
aidée par quelques pays pour combattre
les talibans qui abrité où sam à ben
laden
ceux ci pouvaient être un objectif qu'on
comprenait pour les pays occidentaux
mais lorsque petit à petit la stratégie
a changé et a commencé par vouloir
installer la démocratie en afghanistan
ensuite s'occuper de la libération des
femmes en afghanistan
on voit bien qu'il ya un décalage qui
s'installe entre la réalité du pays et
les objectifs qui sont affichées par les
occidentaux
donc on n'est pas très surpris qu'au
bout de vingt ans tout ceci est échoué
vous disiez tout à l'heure tu as des
risques l'une des conséquences pouvaient
être la dissémination du terrorisme
beaucoup d'afghans elle avait encore un
plus 300 que son parti
tadjikistan voisin beaucoup
d'afghanistan qui tentent de fuir le
pays
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à des
milliers de déplacés
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
nouvelle vague migratoire vers l'europe
oui je pense qu'on peut s'attendre à une
vague migratoire pour une raison simple
depuis 20 ans l'afghanistan a été mêlé à
l'occident les forces occidentales qui
étaient là bas ont commencé à faire du
développement ouvrir des écoles à
éduquer les jeunes femmes etc et toutes
ces personnes ne vont pas accepter ce
que les talibans vont leur proposait
donc soit ils se soumettent soit ils
s'en vont et donc c'est le risque
effectivement de voir un certain nombre
d'afghans
au delà de ce que bien sûr qui ont aidé
les forces internationales
je parlais des interprètes de guides etc
il ya toute une partie de la population
en particulier des femmes qui ne voudra
pas rester dans un pays dans lequel les
talibans imposeront une loi contraire à
ce qu'elles ont connu depuis 20 ans
merci 2 min rincon d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes
général ancien chef de la mission
militaire française aux nations unies
tensions croissantes en afrique du sud
après l'incarcération la semaine
dernière de l'ex président jacob zuma a
accusé de corruption et doute rage
conséquence les frustrations économiques
qui arrivent après
un sixième jour de violences sur les
derniers chiffres le bilan est de 72
morts sur fond de chômage endémique et
de restrictions antico vide les
inquiétudes sur de possibles pénuries
d'essence et de nourriture apparaissent
à johannesburg et durban les deux plus
grandes villes du pays les files de
clients s'allongent devant les
supermarchés l'union africaine appelle
je cite un rétablissement urgent de
l'ordre au risque d'une déstabilisation
régionale
on retrouve tout de suite en direct de
johannesburg place d'ailleurs
journalistes pour arte internationale
c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir pour les tailleurs merci de
répondre à nos questions ce soir sur
arte france vous êtes donc en afrique du
sud
quelle est l'ambiance ce soir dans les
rues de johannesburg calme précaire
violence craintes d'un nouvel
embrasement
voilà toute une famille avec spencer
je viens de passer quelques heures des
membres de la communauté de la police
nous sommes rendus dans différents
quartiers tu t il et ce quartier très
calme mais on pouvait sentir la tension
les gens avaient effectivement très peur
que les scènes à qui ont agité l'afrique
du sud ce week end se répète il n'y a
pas eu de grands incidents récemment
qu'une annonce était fait il ya quelques
heures à partir de demain aura un
déploiement de 500 soldats
supplémentaires
il n'est pas certain que cela apaise la
situation car il ya eu effectivement des
incidences pour insulter et la police
est là mais il doit être sur place pour
les empêcher personne radicaliser disent
que si l'armée déployée alors ils
sortiront en effet le couvre feu est en
place à partir de 21h du soir canada et
les presque vingt deux heures en ce
moment pour des 45 dernières minutes
voyez très peu en véhicule à part à la
rupture de polices couvrent à faire
respecter le calme mais avait déjà été
mise en place
auparavant pour lutter contre le
coronavirus car c'est déjà un problème
auquel l afrique du sud faisait face
pour les skieurs on sait qu'à l'origine
de ces violences il y à l'arrestation
l'incarcération la semaine dernière de
l'ancien président jacob zuma qui a
accusé de corruption accusé d' outrage
également mais ces manifestations est ce
qu'elle dépasse pas 7 cette arrestation
à ce que cette simple arrestation à ce
que sa va pas au delà de
de ce fait la fierté des suisses à fait
d'accord avec vous l'étincelle qui a
allumé la poudre était effectivement
l'arrestation la semaine dernière de
l'ancien président sud africain jacob
zuma a de nombreux soutiens en afrique
du sud
effectivement au départ ce sont six et s
ils sont descendus dans la rue
très rapidement ils ont été rejoints par
une grande foule qui a commencé à
attaquer l écoute et soutien considère
que si la véritable cause et l
arrestation de jacob zuma
on s'attendrait à voir car demandant la
libération de jacob zuma et il n'y a
rien de la sorte
donc ce qui a commencé comme kantari
politique allait elle est devenue une
sorte de situation sans foi des lois et
les gens dans les rues
essaye de récupérer ce qu'il perd je
pense que certains centres commerciaux
étaient complètement oublié lui rester
jusqu'à ce que tu fais et ils se fichent
on a même volé les barres de fer qui
protège des victimes a fait tout ce qui
était possible d'emporter a été levée ce
n'est donc pas une question de pillage
des gens qui montrent aucune tiers par
dijoux tirent profit de cette situation
par le pour récupérer ce qu'ils peuvent
c'est plus de la pauvreté que de la
politique
même si c'est plus de la pauvreté que la
politique et à la presse qui parle
beaucoup en afrique du sud et qui évoque
un pays à genoux après les années sous
main en quoi jacob zuma est il
responsable de la situation actuelle la
population ce qu'elle fait de la
présidence jacob zuma plus pas vous
répondre
[Musique]
beaucoup de personnes effectivement que
ça il a été polluée par la corruption
l'afrique du sud est un pays très riche
nous avons encore par exemple en ce même
que l'électricité
bonjour il n'y a pas d'impasse étaient
disponibles ce qui rend la vie très
difficile du vaccin contre le virus est
très lent parce qu'il n'ya plus d'argent
pour écouter le chant il m'a dit en
cause mais au gouvernement de jacob zuma
pour sa caution de problème les
détournements d'argent sud africaine est
une société toujours très mal et jacob
zuma vient du grand toulouse
mais même si vous de sunu ils veulent
ils la soutiennent encore jacob zuma
c'est pour cela que telle ou telle
action par exemple ne pourrait pas être
la solution car beaucoup de personnes
voteraient encore aujourd'hui pour lui
merci beaucoup pour l'asc ailleurs
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste pour
rt internationale c'est la fin de cette
émission prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes on se
retrouve à 22h heure française pour une
2 milliards d'euros
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des lignes ont aujourd'hui on a
une gauche extrême
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame 50 négociations
politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre 20 perd gros là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations
les choses sont en train de se caler de
se mettre en place est ce que les choses
sont totalement fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution insultes et
d'une nécessité technologique absolue
les terres rares sont au coeur des défis
du 21e siècle c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour tous les pays puisque leur accès
est aujourd'hui principalement chinois
en l'état actuel des capacités minières
connu la part chinoise et réserve
mondiale est de l'ordre de 37 % dans la
cadre de la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis la chine utilise sa position
comme levier de négociations mais il est
clair qu'avec les pénuries et les
tensions que nous allons connaître sur
certaines terres rares il faut envisager
d'autres solutions
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans les oui la guerre est
possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
hommage aux victimes de l'attentât de
nice qui a fait 86 morts le 14 juillet
2016 présent tout à l'heure dans la cité
azuréenne pour une journée de
commémoration cinq ans après le premier
ministre jean castex et le garde des
sceaux eric dupond moretti
avec en toile de fond la lutte contre le
terrorisme
après une année sans kobe 19 oblige la
france à renouer ce matin avec son
traditionnel défilé militaire le dernier
du mandat d' emmanuel macron parmi les
participants des soldats de la task
force takouba qui réunit huit nations
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme au
sahel
et ce alors que le chef de l'état a
annoncé la fin de l'opération barkan
dans la région pour le début 2022 parce
qu'un an après la terrible explosion du
port de beyrouth